you popped up you did a cameo in in
tiger King I know that you visited him
alright yesterday on my day off I went
to the GW Zoo
shoutout to exotic Joe I got two more
Tigers I didn't do a cameo the law
states that when you do something say
something becomes public property so
you're right and correct
I we were we were traveling back and
forth from Dallas OKC
so I see a sign that says we have tigers
white tigers I love white tigers that's
my weakness wait so I go and the
gentleman is there he's you know long
hair the shirts you know yes I met that
he's there and like you know I tell
people all the time
me and friendly to somebody doesn't mean
that that we're friends
I have no have no affiliation with him
or a zoo I like animals yeah every
country knows my name are made a large
donations too you know for animals to
have food shelter all that good stuff so
I go there listen guy had a nice park he
had like 200 G cats you let me get some
you know little kitty sauce hey I want
to buy the kitties so and that term by
means donation you know I want to buy
these kitties they'll be mine I'm gonna
give you a donation I get to come back
to see him whatever so you know I do
that two years later I come back the
other guy pulls me to the side and said
there's some stuff going on you might
not want to come back here again I never
came back and I think that was 78 years
ago and then finally I'm watching the
DVD because I followed what was
happening and then I never saw one I see
myself and I was like up here we go and
the next area I was going crazy but
America I do not harm animals I love
animals so thank you very much
yeah yeah well what if you think of Joe
exotic when you met him he seems like
it'd be a pretty entertaining guy yes
she was he was one you know he was one
of those guys that go to auditions every
day and they want to be a star so bad
they'll just do everything and guess
what now now he's
one of the most famous people in America
but you know who was really funny the
guy with no teeth he was funny oh yeah
he's got teeth now yeah those
yeah I think he got implants he probably
got a little money came his way and he
got some teeth okay but that's not his
brand no he's not gonna be for pretty
teeth to go back to the no teeth look
man well I'll get that message to him